don't fight in the
North/south
fight every battle everywhere
always
in your mind
For centuries our families fought together
against their common enemy despite their differences together
We need to do the same if we're gonna survive
The enemy is real
It's always been real
when the snows fall
And the white winds blow
the Lone Wolf dies
but the pack survives
Hey, everybody new game of thrones trailer. Let's break it down
There's a new round of the giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on this video
So what is this talk about Sansa saying the lone wolf dies?
But the pack survives it sounds like littlefinger is speaking to her in the trailer
Teaching her to fight battles in her mind while jon snow is fighting the real physical
Battles trying to form the alliance in the north and then you see this backdrop of all the wars happening across Westeros
So it gets really crazy later in the trailer. Let's just go through this shot by shot. This is nuts
You see the gate opening up at the wall Jon snow in the wildlings stepping out into the frozen north
We get a shot of the lannister controlled King's landing. It looks like the peasants aren't too
Happy if you remember way back
During season two they had that big Joffrey riot where they killed one of the great septons and they almost carried Santa off
Cersei looks like she's back down in the black cells where she's keeping Septa unella
I know we've seen a lot of the mountain
But it's going to be really grisly just to think about the things that they've been doing to her down there more of Daenerys
landing at Dragonstone
And then walking around the map table aurilla slowly making her way back to Winterfell
This looks like Jamie's still at King's landing walking around the battlements littlefinger back in the crypts
This is a repeated shot from the last trailer
They keep talking about battles as people are sharpening their blades
So it's just people preparing for war and even though there's going to be a lot of wars this season
I think we're expecting season 8 to be like a six episode long battle like every single episode
Daenerys Walking on the Beach on Dragonstone
The cool thing about this the way they shot this you can see this outline of what looks like a dragon edged in the rock
Here, it's just a natural formation of the rocks, but I love the imagery
She's literally walking into a dragon as she's walking into Dragonstone that Jon snow
Voice-over is also very apropos - he's talking about banding together to fight common enemy
He's talking about Robert's rebellion
Fighting the Targaryen but in reality because they cut all of the night king and the white walkers into this trailer
You're really thinking about everyone in Westeros banding together to fight their common enemy
Because as the enemy is real and then they get all the shots of the white walkers
But this is Daenerys pulling down Stannis's banner if she walks in we finally get a better shot of the dragons
We've only seen Drogon in the previous trailer, but this is just such a beautiful look at Dragonstone
I love this worried concerned look on Tyrians face shot a theon with the Greyjoy battles
There's a couple more big greyjoy shots in this trailer to grey worm looking like he's getting ready to assault casterly Rock
Suddenly you remember that story that tyrion told about how his father gave him the task of fixing the plumbing in casterly Rock?
So the waves put it below like lannister gold out of their minds this looks like their infiltration
Point if you look at the map here Lannisport casterly Rock are right here
So they probably sailed into this bay pot and bring in at Winterfell
We had a shot of them training in that last behind-the-scenes trailer
So it looks like pods trying to get better Brienne
just kicking the crap out of him in a lovely jump to the shot of the hound way up in the frozen north so he's
Definitely part of Jon Snow's
band like when you see them all circled up here you see them running during different parts of the trailer
fighting with the night King
They're standing here will looks like the fist of the first men he along with Beric dondarrion
And the blaming sword that you saw Stannis use you can think of it as azor Ahai
But I love the way that it just lights up on command
He doesn't stick it in the fire
It literally just lights up
This shot of the unsullied being taken down by arrows looks like it's connected to the shot of Jamie on the field with the archers
Just more the unsullied
charging the Lannister infantrymen
more of the Greyjoy battle as they're burning each other ships and then so many of you been asking me when is bran
Finally going to fly. This is how bran is flying
He's flying over the army of the dead looking at the night king so you see the eye of the crow sort of switched
So you can tell that he's ward into it
That's what the three-eyed raven meant when he said that you will fly someday, and then you see the night king notices him
So he can sense bran's presence this shot a brand here actually makes
It look like he's at winterfell in this wheelchair with Davos here
So this might be connected to Sansa him telling everyone about jon. Snow's heritage, so it might be from before Jon
Snow goes up to the wall or it could be connected to this shot of brand warding all the over the army of the dead
In just for the record even though he does have the flaming sword I do not think that he's azor ahai
But remember in the books how he gave his last kiss of life to lady Stoneheart
He's been resurrected six times he had like one more to go. He gave that last one to Lady Stoneheart
Maybe he'll do the same thing up north of the wall because sauce is talking about the lone wolf die
So maybe he'll give the kiss of life to Jon snow this season
We get all these gray joy chips making their way into Blackwater bay just reminding you of the blackwater
Episode this time they might not have as much wildfire
So it'll be interesting to see how they deal with that the unsullied in formation getting ready to assault casterly Rock
So this looks like it's connected to that shot of grey worm is sneaking beneath
Casterly rock so that they could get a strike force in so they can get the regular army through
Daenerys on the battlements at Dragonstone Jaime riding across a field of fire
It looks like drogon after the archers took down some of the unsullied Drogon rode in and just roasted the entire Battlefield
field of fire style during Aegon's conquest
So there's a lot of parallels for Aegon's conquest in season 7
Just more the greyjoy battle blowing the crap out of each other
And then all over westeros the battles get cranked up you see torment taking a swing at the army of the dead
You see Drogon riding ahead of the dothraki bloodrider. 'he's you see
Theon and Yara entering their battle that's connected to all those ships blowing up really awesome looking lannister
Infantrymen that have absolutely no idea what's coming for them, and this is probably one of my favorite shots of the trailer?
What looks like the fist of the first men with Jon snow Beric dondarrion, and it looks like tormond?
Just getting assaulted by the army of the dead
Missandei and Grey worm action if you're a big fan of their relationship
I know a lot of people make comments about what the mechanics of this relationship are going to be
Because he's been cut that's the whole idea that
He's unsullied and you might not be able to tell by looking at this, but this is finally jon snow at Dragonstone
You can tell by the rock formations in the background
So this has got to be from at least episode two three four however fast you think he's going to make a beeline for
Dragonstone to treat with Daenerys Jon Snow Vs.
White Walkers round two with longclaw even though this looks like could be white walkers
I think this is actually from the drogon battle after he's lit the field up like you have all these soldiers riding through the field
Of fire back on the beach at dragonstone, and this actually looks like our first legit shot of your on Greyjoy
Just having it out with theon and Yara's men and this here this actually looks like so much fun
So this is a dragon stone with drogo looking down. Which is probably what tyrion is looking up at really worried
we actually got some behind the scenes for this you see tyrion sort of scanning his eyes around at this big green screen thing as
It's looking at him while it looks like he's getting ready to crap his pants this shot looks like it could be jon
Snow as Sansa says the lone wolf dies, but the pack survives
but remember there are a number of people that are dressed up and furs, so
Trailers always a bit misleading this could even be Meera riding on horseback
but I love this shot here of jon snow with longclaw that reminds you of
Episode 9 battle of the bastards as he was being charged down by all those Boltons on horseback
so it's sort of the mirror for that except this time he has the
Army of the dead that's charging him so we can just cross our fingers and hope that a dragon will arrive in time to save
Him let me know in the comments
What's your favorite part of the trailer and what do you think about the idea of little fingers voice over to Sansa?
About her fighting battles in the mind in her coming to the conclusion that the lone wolf very clearly talking about Jon snow dies
But the pack survives in what that says about their relationship this season that just sounds crazy
But I have a couple more game of thrones videos planned for later this week, and I'll say congratulations to Tommo
You're the latest
Giveaway winner leave all your requests for bonus videos in the comments below you can click here for all the other behind the scenes videos
And you can click here for all my other season 7 videos. Thank you so much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!